salut on est samedi matin il est
beaucoup trop tôt et on va attaquer le
troisième masters classes il faut que je
vous dise quelque chose il faut que je
le partage avec vous ses master class
les films et là déjà il ya une heure en
fait les cris les tourner le film et en
double caméra et j'ai eu un problème de
vidéos j'ai perdu tous les rushes avant
même de les monter j'ai failli arrêter
le mental blog de cette déception on
s'en fiche c'est le troisième masters
class fut très content de le faire enfin
de leur faire enfin je ne sais plus vous
ai posé la question hier sur tous les
réseaux sociaux de ce que vous vouliez
pour ce master cassez vous m'avez
répondu m'avait répondu plein de choses
hyper pertinents hyper intéressante
sachez que je les note tout dans mon
cahier mon cahier à idées elles sont
tellement intéressante et pertinente
qu'il faut que je travaille un peu
dessus dans le sens où il faut que
j'écrive un peu les idées que j'organise
que je vous fasse quelque chose d'assez
clair en fait c'est pédagogique et on a
reparlé du boulier
vous savez cette semaine j'ai reçu mon
nouveau billet que j'aime les bouliers
les impacts j'aime bien parce que c'est
un très bon outil en fait ça permet de
calculer plus rapidement souvent aussi
rapidement que ça parce que j'ai pas
elle devenue un rien à faire et ce à
deux autres avantages ferrand les
chiffres concrets à l'aide des boules
qui assure les tiges c'est palpable en
fait c'est de la matière et surtout pour
le calcul mental quand on maîtrise bien
le boulier qu'on a d'imagination on peut
imaginer un boulier devant soi on a
juste à faire bouger les boules dans sa
tête et alors là on a plus qu'à lire le
résultat dans ce master classe numéro 3
je vous apprendre à vous servir d'un
boulier chinois parce qu'il ya aussi le
boulier japonais il le boulier russie
anna m'a beaucoup de versions le boulier
chinois
il se compose de treize tiges et de deux
parties donc la partie supérieure
les petits nerfs ça dans la personne est
in her les vidéos et les billes du bac
on appelle les une aire cette barre
transversale qui les sépare ça va être
un petit peu notre ligne de lecture tout
ce qu'on rapproche de cette barre c'est
ce qu'on va vraiment lire ça a été un
des premiers systèmes pour calculer qui
a été inventée celui ci le boulier
chinois il était à inventer en six ans
avant jésus-christ en six ans avant
jésus-christ que vous savez comment
c'est que c'est en six ans avant
jésus-christ ils ont calculé avec un
boulier
pas bête et là vous allez voir que c'est
hyper simple de s'en servir et que c'est
drôle parce qu'après ça devient un jeu
je vous jure après on aime se servir du
boulier ça devient un jeu en fait ça
devient très ludique ilse bouger les
petites billes comme ça sur sur les
tiges
enfin je crois que ça peut faire ça à
d'autres personnes que moi j'espère ça
me rassurerait en fait il ya deux choses
à savoir je vous disais sur le boulier
le premier
la première chose c'est que cette tige
là la première elle correspond aux unis
et la deuxième au dizaine ensuite aux
centaines ou milliers aux dizaines de
milliers ou centaines de milliers ou
millions etc etc
c'est la première chose à savoir c'est
pas très dur la suite c'est pas plus
compliqué la suite c'est la manière dont
va écrire un chiffre si je veux écrire
un je vais pousser la vie un prêt de ma
barre transversale ça c'est un est en
fait vous allez rien comprendre c'est
que tu es vachement mis en valeur avec
la gopro chill mes mains à tout moment
vous savez quoi vous avez plus
m'entendre en off
et moi je vais bouger le système pour
que vous puissiez bien voir alors si je
veux dessiner un chiffre sur mon
boullier on va dire le représenter
si je veux un tout simplement je vais
pousser un dans ma barre des unités de
jeu pousser le deuxième 3 le troisième 4
le 4e et 5 le cinquième
mais quand j'ai tous mes nerfs qui sont
montés alors je peux les replacer par un
kiné est donc en descendant une de ces
boules là c'est bull là elles valent 5
ans fait donc à la place de ces cinq là
je vais redescendre une comme ça mais
pour pas me perdre dans ce que je fais
tout en descendant
makine r je redescende et s'inclinèrent
est donc là je viens de symboliser 5 6 7
8 9 et 10 et encore une fois j'ai mais
s'inclinèrent do monte donc je vais
redescendre et une clean air à la place
et là j'ai mes deux qui n'est requis
sont mises et oui j'ai dix dans mes
unités vous comprenez que j'ai dix juste
ici donc je vais changer se disent là
contre le 1 de ma dizaine c'est tout
aussi logique et tout temps là mon temps
ici je vais remonter ces deux là pour
pas me perds donc je mets mon douala et
mon doigt là et je monte la vraie
position des doigts sur 1 à bac c'est
comme ça on va prendre juste comme ça
déjà pour commencer voilà vous savez
tout ce qui est à savoir je vous
apprendre aujourd'hui les additions les
soustractions les multiplications on va
pas faire les divisions les extractions
de racine carrée pour le moment par
contre si vous voulez qu'on fasse un
jour ça y'a pas de soucis vous me le
dites dans les commentaires et je ferai
une vidéo un peu plus poussées sur le
boulier si ça vous tente mais déjà
addition soustraction et multiplication
alors oui l'addition va commencer facile
on va dire 12 x 37 par exemple donc je
marquais monde 12 ici et pour pas
l'oublier je marque est le 37 de l'autre
côté
donc là 12 + 37 1 2 3 pour le 30 et 5 6
7 pour le 737 c'est pour pas oublier ce
que je vous calculer ça c'est mon 12
donc une dizaine et deux unités et cette
unité clé si je les ai tout est ici
donc je vais le faire quand même
lentement mais là je mets 5
la jeune et 2 c'était les sept qu'il y
avait là que je viens de symbolisée ici
du coup je les enlève je les ai calculé
et les trois dizaines que j'ai là je
l'ajouté à la dizaine qui alla donc
j'inverse et voilà j'ai donc mon 49 12
et 37 49 évidemment tort nous avait bien
compris le principe on a fait un peu
plus compliqué disons 137 à et 145 béton
les toits 145 j'ai mis mon ca 45 ici
pour pas l'oublier mon 137 ici donc le
calcul vous faut encore lentement
d'abord mes unités il faut que je
rajoute le 5
ici donc lui je vais descendre lui voilà
je les rajouter là là vous voyez que
j'en ai deux donc vous souvenez de la
règle je les élimine en en montant un de
ce côté en même temps ensuite j'ai ces
quatre là a rajouté ici donc un com
s'est plaint j'inverse 2 3 et 4
ça c'est fait et un jazz ajouté là juste
là et ça nous fait 280 237 et 145 font
bien 282 évidemment allégeant fin
dernier un tout petit peu plus
rapidement peut-être histoire de bien
dire voilà 257 comme ça ça nous en met
un petit peu partout et puis on va dire
trois cent dix neuf pour en faire un
gros ici alors 319 et 257 donc tout
d'abord je rajoutais cela ici ça nous
fait tac tac
voilà ensuite il faut que je rajoute
celui ci si donc là c'est pas compliqué
juste que je fais ça l'étroit ici donc
là du coup je les change ici et ça nous
fait 319 plus de 157 égale 576 je vais
vite volontairement au lieu de vous
faire plein d'exemples puisque comme
c'est une vidéo de toute manière vous
pourrez revenir en arrière vous pouvez
revoir vous pouvez aussi tourner la tête
comme moi vous faites ce que vous voulez
c'est ça qui est bien avec les master
class en vidéo je reviens sur le boulier
maintenant pour les soustractions s'est
pas beaucoup plus compliqué j'ai
commencé volontairement par une
soustraction pas évidente on va faire 41
- u17 comme ça on va être obligés
d'enlever cette 2 1 ça va me permettre
de vous le montrer parce que c'est la
seule question qu'on peut se poser
comment ça se passe quand on fait une
addition comme ça comme comment je fais
pour enlever ces sept unités de cette
unité là et b en fait il faut que j'en
ai plus ici il faut que j'en ai beaucoup
plus
du coup je vais descendre une boule
d'ici pour récupérer ces deux là là déjà
ça devient intéressant parce que là j'ai
11 et 11 - 7 ça je sais le faire ça fait
4 donc du coup je mets mon 4 et
maintenant on aimerait simplement une
dizaine enlevé de ces trois dizaines et
ça me fait 24 je crois qu'il n'y a pas
plus simple que les soustractions avec
un boulier avec encore une fois aucun
risque d'erreur je commence à avoir mal
à la tête à la mettre dans tous les sens
et on termine avec ce que j'aime le plus
faire avec un boulier c'est mon petit
bonbon c'est ce que j'adore vraiment
faire ce sont les multiplications et le
but avec un collier c'est vraiment
ludique à faire moi je m'amuse à en
faire pendant que j'ai un truc qui
chargent sur l'ordi ou des trucs comme
ça vous allez y prendre goût vraiment il
faut juste le prendre le temps un petit
peu d'essayer pour info d'ailleurs les
bouliers y en a à tous les prix quand je
me mets un petit peu comme ça maintenant
c'est n'importe quoi
le bullying en a à tous les prix on a 5
euros il y en a 10 euros vin rouge où il
y en a qui coûte très très cher parce
qu'ils sont des dents dans des matériaux
pression va dire en règle générale pour
10 euros 20 euros vous avez un très bon
boullier je sais pas ce qui fait un bon
bout lier le fait que les boules elle
glisse sur la tige
vous pouvez en acheter un vraiment aussi
vous donner des adresses de sites il ya
les éditions mater l'eau qui en font des
bouliers me vous en trouver partout de
toute manière j'ai pas de jardin à vous
conseiller
très franchement un boulier chinois
simplifié moi quoi on va commencer avec
un truc très basique on va dire 12 x 12
comme on sait tous que ça fait 144 donc
je mets 12 ici je remets 12 là-bas pour
fameux perdre pour savoir quel est mon
multiplicateur il ya quelque chose à
savoir pour les multiplications cclat ce
coup ci on va compter de la gauche vers
la droite toujours de la gauche vers la
droite je mets mon doigt sur mon chiffre
qui est le plus à gauche donc là ce sont
sur les dizaines pour savoir toujours au
j'en suis et je mettrai des d'abord le
premier chiffre de ce côté là à savoir
les dizaines également le résultat que
va faire la multiplication entre ces
deux endroits je vais l'appliquer aux
tiges qui précède celle où j'ai mon
doigt ses terres je m'explique c'est
très simple là j'ai fait un x 1
ça fait 1 donc je rajoute un ici c'est
tous ceux arrêtés de jean emile 2 3 3 4
4 5-5 6 is et c'est sûr été 12 et ben
j'aurais fait 12 comme ça le résultat
était 38 j'aurais mis 38 comme ça en
fait j'aurais toujours placé sur
résultats avant cette tige je ne touche
pas la fille joue j'ai mon doigt
quand je m'occupe de le multiplier avec
le premier chiffre de l'autre côté donc
1 x 1 ça fait et ensuite je vais
multiplier cette tige là avec cette tige
là et je vais afficher le résultat sur
cette tige je ne vais surtout pas
d'additionner faux-pas de l'additionner
il faut l'affiché donc la 2 x 1
ça fait donc deux ça c'est fait et
maintenant mon doigt se décale d'un cran
vers la droite et je refais la même
chose deux fois 1 ça fait deux donc je
rajoute 2 sur la tige précédentes ici et
maintenant deux fois deux ça fait 4 4
que j'affiche sur la tige ou j'ai mon
doigt et ça fait bien 144 2 soit 12 144
est ce que c'est bien clair nous enfin
dernier un peu plus rapidement pour la
route on va dire 366 pour la route j'ai
vraiment dit on va en faire un pour la
route 366 et le nombre de vidéos que je
fais cette année c'est pour ça que
j'aimais ça et on va dire 52 puisque je
le fais en 52 semaines on va multiplier
366 par 52 366 c'est ici et 52 c'est là
donc je mets mon doigt sur d'abord les
chiffres qui sont toujours à gauche
trois fois 5 ça fait quinze donc je mets
mon 15 comme cela avant la tige ensuite
trois fois deux ça fait 6 donc je
dessine mensys ici j'arrive là ça nous
fait 6 6 x 5 ça fait trente donc je fais
1 2 3 et 0 là et si soit 2 ça fait douze
donc un pour le dise de 12 et 2 ici pour
le 12 je j'affiche le chiffre des unités
ici et je passe à ce douala ici 6 x 5 30
1 2 3 je rajoute mon 30
là vous avez vu j'ai une conversion à
faire je descends là mais là j'en ai
encore une affaire je remonte là et je
termine par mon 6 x 2 qui nous font 12
donc une dizaine et le 2 2 12 et voilà
ça nous fait le résultat de 19000 32 et
52 x 360 si ça fait bien dix neuf mille
32 bon j'aurais quand même eu le courage
de l'art offert enfin le courage on va
dire plutôt la motivation de refaire
cette vidéo sur le boulier de tenir
c'est un truc qui me passionne donc
vraiment ça me dérange pas de
l'expliquer si vous avez des questions
vous me demandez il ya pas de soucis on
peut en reparler
j'ai volontairement pas faire un master
class trop long parce que je me dis que
la avoir plein d'exemples ça sert à rien
c'est tout l'intérêt d'avoir ces vidéos
d'avoir ce mental blog c'est que vous
pouvez faire pause regard en arrière
essayez de le faire de leur faire
indéfiniment j'ai pas besoin de vous
donner trop d'exemples je crois vraiment
utiliser un boulier vous allez à dar ès
jeux pas pourquoi je prince taxons cette
nuit on a passé les 1500 abonnés c'est
énorme 1500 abonnés je vous ai annoncé
un objectif c'est qu'à 2500 abonnés on
va se faire une rencontre ensemble en
live sur internet c'est à dire on va
faire un live de deux heures d'au moins
deux heures jeudi deux heures mais je
sais même pas si on s'arrêtera au bout
de deux heures on fera un vrai live
ensemble chacun chez soi on va pouvoir
se voir on va pouvoir s'écrire se parler
faire plein de trucs à 2501 bonne et
voilà c'est mon objectif c'est mon but
c'est le cran que je dois dépasser
ben je suis tout petit 1 et vous pouvez
m'aider à dépasser ce camp là c'est à
dire vous pouvez partager ses vidéos
s'il vous plaît s'il ya des vidéos qui
vous plaisent de qui vous font rire de
ce qui vous intéresse vous pouvez les
partager
quand je dis partager c'est pas que sur
internet vous pouvez vraiment parler aux
gens autour de vous en faites dans votre
quotidien vous connaissez ce que ça
pourrait aider c'est que ça pourrait
simplement intéressé partager cette
vidéo
parlez-en soyons 2500 faisons cet apéro
ensemble virtuellement chacun de notre
côté de caméras bref
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et rendez vous
demain à 11 heures pour le prochain
mandat le blog ciao